the Joe Rogan experience cuz I have
mental illness you do you [ __ ]
get it together give it to a mental
doctor I can't
- LLL miss you have a vitamin for you
what is it
cocaine that's what [ __ ] me up by GAD
was a coke addict thanks man so we're
going off now full circle imagine if you
were like a slightly overweight person
who might might be burped more on the
feminine side Bert and get really mad at
me like their purse no Hubbard I'm not
talking about birth
you said fat guy that's a policy doesn't
exist love you Bert I got someone that
doesn't exist if I was an overweight
person who was sensitive super sensitive
would you just choose that moment to be
a victim yeah would you how would you
say would you say you cruel Joe why
because you don't respect people like me
struggle what did you do what did I say
you know what you said you Pig
well that's a [ __ ] alpha male you
can't honey can you say that you just I
just said something gonna tell me Jaime
what did I say you hear what I said
offended pig you don't even tell them
what I said call him a [ __ ] or having
Ellen [ __ ] mother right there some
[ __ ] though right okay a lot of
people that have mental illness and it's
legit there's a few [ __ ] that are
faking it they're just [ __ ] Wow you
can't say that how come you can't say
that because you know it's true it's not
everyone yeah but why look there's some
people that are just full of [ __ ] you
tell me anything like right everybody a
lot of [ __ ] all the grifters the
world some aren't gonna claim depressed
come on they pretend to be heirs they
pretend to be dukes and they're not
gonna pretend to be depressed is
ridiculous when a guy is called a [ __ ]
it means he's to make what's called a
[ __ ] it means she's too aggressive do
any of us have any idea what this word
even means that was so good that tweet
was so good I wish I wrote it cuz that
that point is so good yeah I'm glad she
put it on Twitter so no one could steal
it it's almost like that idea like that
idea is like very poignant like that
yeah what is that [ __ ] work
you know like [ __ ] can be great but it
can also be weak but a [ __ ] can give
birth I mean it got a damn bowling ball
all comes out of that thing [ __ ] are
always strong 10-pound babies come out
of a [ __ ] imagine a 10-pound baby
coming out of your dick and then respect
that thing I'm saying I mean what dick
drives the [ __ ] be weak it's more like
compliant but it's not weak look it's
also desirable pussy's not desirable
it's a man when of desirable if I called
you a [ __ ] what's the first thought if
something Lucy oh really yeah really
really yeah yeah right so what it when
it when uh when a guy calls another guy
a [ __ ] is a cheap insult meaning what
well sometimes you ready to fight you
just want to provoke this guy so pussy's
the word counter-puncher so what you're
calling a guy great sexual object
[ __ ] nice thing I want to foxy just
letting them know we're getting about to
get down you nice thing I want to [ __ ]
all the time get over here if you watch
guys fight half of half of it is talking
[ __ ] to each other before you get down
yeah you just yeah instigate the fight
there's a well it's also it's not just
instigating you're getting someone
scared you're making some nerve or
you're trying to measure your confidence
level versus there yeah who's got the
most if you can get someone nervous
though if you can live get emit get so
nervous you can decrease their
performance by a significant margin for
sure it gets in there scare him yeah you
can scare someone I could be really
ready to go but you have to be really
ready to go but everybody here could try
to scare someone they took a swing at
Joe Tyson talked about it every so many
competitors talk to Olin when they would
see him they get nervous course so they
we get scared and then fight worse
because they get scared 100% everybody
um you see that guy you're like he
didn't have to talk much he let his
performances talk you know and he the
most scary thing he ever said the
scariest thing he ever said was we saw
how dare they threatened me how dare
these mere mortals yeah well I know
their primitive skills is it crazy that
he has such a feminine voice he's the
masculine dude my favorite boxer of all
time to watch
[Applause]